nevada state bank has continued to serve
the financial needs of its clients
throughout the challenges of covenanting
and they're now being recognized
for those services here's more on that
[Music]
nevada state bank is special for many
reasons as a colleague of the bank
we are very focused on creating an
engaging work environment
we even have a team a colleague
engagement team
that conducts events and activities for
our colleagues
we want them to know that we want them
to have a full employee experience it's
not just about serving our clients which
is of course so important but they could
do that at any other bank
we want them to have opportunities to
develop themselves so we were top
10 in the forbes best in-state employer
award which was
really exciting and then also we
received
third place for large companies in the
top workplaces nevada award
as well as receiving the values award
the values award was extremely important
to us because the core values of the
bank
are the absolute pillar upon which we do
business and upon which our colleagues
choose to be employed with us and so
those core that values award was really
touching for us so nevada state bank has
eight
core values and they are accountability
adaptability
community communication extraordinary
service
development teamwork and respect
[Music]
we also recently our entire executive
management committee
went out to almost every branch across
the state to check in on our branch
colleagues who have been serving our
clients
daily since this pandemic began and we
wanted to tell them
thank you for everything you've done and
so you know every single branch was
visited almost entirely and it was such
a great experience because we were
showing them
directly that appreciation we also allow
our colleagues to give back to the
community and that is so
important we all live in our communities
in which we work
and so we allow our colleagues to go and
volunteer in the community nevada state
bank has several upcoming events
one that's coming really soon is
november 1st and that's our virtual
jdrf1 walk
terry shirey our president and ceo is
the chairman of that walk this year
we're really excited for that event
our branches have been raising dollars
and they're going to be virtually
walking miles to support that effort
on november 5th and 6th we will be
collecting food through a drive-through
to benefit the las vegas rescue mission
so that's a canned food drive
that will meet our social distancing
needs but also support that effort
and then in december we'll be supporting
the kluc
toy drive for help of southern nevada
and we've participated in that for many
years
for any additional information about
these events you can follow our social
medias or facebook twitter instagram
pages
and then also check into uh one of the
branches when you're doing your business
there
we'll have bins in the branches for our
kluc toy drive and you can also make
other donations for our other events
while you're in the branch
we want to thank nevada state bank for
being one of our community pride
partners